and as we hit the milestone of a million
people vaccinated here in clark county
it's important for women to alert their
doctor before getting a mammogram
denise valdez has the warning in today's
buddy check 8 report
chances are you've heard of the side
effects of maybe having a sore arm
fatigue fever after getting the cobit
vaccine
another symptom is swollen lymph nodes
they can appear on mammography and
ultrasound
days after vaccination and could be
mistaken
for breast cancer swollen lymph nodes
are the body's normal response to the
vaccine
it means your system is making
antibodies to fight the copin 19
infection but radiologists should keep
this side effect
in mind when viewing breast images in an
article published in clinical imaging
researchers featured four case studies
of women who had just received their
first shot
now in this image a 57 year old female
with a single enlarged
left lymph node was detected eight days
after receiving her first dose
in her left arm the swollen lymph node
is highlighted here in blue and red
however her right breast appears normal
overall data from the centers for
disease control and prevention
show 11.6 percent of vaccine recipients
experience adenopathy after one dose
and 16 do so after the second dose
the large lymph node typically appeared
within two to four
days after the vaccination so given the
likelihood this side effect will develop
in a significant number of patients
you really need to let the radiologist
know that you've had the vaccine
and when because it could impact your
diagnosis
for buddy check i'm denise valdez back
to you